مشهد واحد يحتمل روايتين احداهما ترقى
لجريمه حرب مقاطع فيديو انتشرت على وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي تظهر مقتل 11 جنديا
روسيا على يد القوات الاوكرانيه
ماكيكا في اقليم لوجان يعود تاريخه الى
اواسط نوفمبر الجاري
في الروايه الروسيه يبدو المشهد اعداما
جماعيا لجنود الروس استسلموا للقوات
الاوكرانيه لتتهم موسكو
القانون الدولي
مستنيده الى مقطعين احدهما يصور الجنود
رافع الايدي بينما الاخر يظهرهم مدرجين
بدمائهم عبر لقطات طائره مسيره جهات روسيه
رسميه عده تحركت لادانت كيف لجنه التحقيق
في الجرائم فتحت قضيه جنائيه ونادت
الخارجيه الروسيه الاطراف الدوليه لادانه
الجريمه
المقاطع والمصوره دليل على المجزره التي
ارتكبها جنود الاوكرانيون بحق اسرى حرب
عزل الروايه الاوكرانيه تاخذ القصه في منح
اخر مؤكده ان الجنود الروس تظاهر
بالاستسلام لمحاوله فتح النار على
الاوكرانيين فيما سمتها حاله الدفاع عن
النفس نفيتا ايتها من بالاعدام الجماعي
لا يمكن اعتبارهم اسرع حرب وينبغي معاقبه
اولئك الذين يريدون استخدام حمايه القانون
الدولي للقتل
الامم المتحده من جهتها قالت انها على علم
بالمقاطع وتجرى تحقيقاتها للتحقق منها
لتضع كيف امام احتمال محاكمه بتهمه جريمه
حرب تقلب ميزان الحرب في اوكرانيا الى عمر
العربيه